peux-tu trouver cet échec et mat en un
coup avec les blancs au moins d'une
minute attention c'est pas aussi facile
que ça en a l'air je te laisse mettre
pause si tu veux chercher sinon voici
mon raisonnement ici j'ai vite éliminé
tous les échecs puisquà chaque fois le
roi noir trouver une case de fuite si on
saute avec un cavalier il va se cacher
dans le coin si on joue dam F6 échec qui
va manger notre cavalier si on mange ce
pion pour profiter du clouage encore une
fois il peut s'abriter ici fou prend5 ça
sert à rien il peut nous bouffer et donc
aucun coup légal et logique qui marche
je me suis dit il y a angill sous roche
et donc les noirs viennent forcément de
jouer E5 au dernier coup pour nous
permettre la magique prise en passant et
chez kemat le cou vient terrasser le roi
dans la grande diagonale et le pion ne
pas faire bouclier puisqu'il est cloué
as-tu trouvé l'astuce si oui dis-le nous
en commentaire